I have to expect it in the field however
doesn't mean because it's an exercise
because because if the scholars Muslim
Scholars are not expect like Muslim
schools those who are fighting
righteousness and when they speak about
Allah they speak with knowledge you know
because so alhamdulillah we don't
allowed to Blind for no one we are only
to follow
we don't use the word blinding because
blindly means there's no proof you know
we only follow without any restriction
the Quran and the Sunnah and the Ishmael
every scholar always
give you a statement with no proven Upon
Us
exactly yes
you take the Habit serious of course
we're joking around here
foreign
and so studies biography and we don't
just follow a book we have we still have
Islam now so you still have to not
understand so in every generation we
know the person very well we start this
biography for example to show you that
the Muslim scholar that's okay too
serious not playing around there was a
man
and he was his expertise in criticizing
people and praising them so he will tell
you this daughter from this person his
father used to narrate Hadith his father
yeah so they're asking for his own
father can we take hide it from him yes
and islamically we have to respect our
father Yes you cannot say they're lying
all right yes but now watch this
head down he said my father is not right
and how did you don't text from him so
he was a guy's own father for the sake
of protecting Hadith you understand yes
bukhari when he came to Baghdad the
scores of Hadith came together and they
got his book and they start mixing these
nuts yes so there's a text and there's
it's not oh yeah so it's not from one
text they put it on another text yes and
they said to him we're gonna test
you they said you said in your book
the third one he said no the first one
that is not the chain of narration the
first chain of narration is for the
other one yes so thus we say okay now
that one talking about in the biggest
goal so they said to him now yeah you
can take hiding from him so this goes
hard if not anyone said no there was
schoolers sitting down verifying
clarifying investigating everything yeah
we're still having our time our time
there is some Muslims here who give
Tower people do not listen to them why
because the opposed for understanding
they're my brothers in Islam you know
and I love them no doubt but because
they say things
me and the brothers here they'll come
out openly and they said don't take from
them understand because indeed is more
important thank you yes my problem thank
you sir and my problem here is this yes
all this what you said about the hadiths
and the narration and how the narration
happened yeah
there's only three people why for
example imagine my father he's 80 years
old
and I'm 20. yes my father tells me
something yes because remember this this
to come out very early as well so
literally Santa's father is older than
the sun maybe 10 years yes so sometimes
there's four generation in one time yes
you understand sometimes he's the latest
sort of it to me from you and what I
have to do I said no before I take it I
have to come to you and ask you and I
said you know I can I can escape you I
mean Escape you and come to him so
that's how the squads were doing it and
so we have a documents and we're having
an oral teaching now them documents so
both of them
the documents you say this this
that documents now
that document
what do you mean no for example
there is a manuscript called
um
so in his manuscript which is in is in
um uh with our country next to Germany
Australian of uh
so he will say the message said and
guess what maturity of those narrations
is the same narrations
narrated
150 years later so we still have a
manuscript backdated also we have
manuscript backdated in an Emma time
which himself final fight his many
manuscripts but date even the prophet
Muhammad his companies for example we
have a manuscript of
um abandonment
is
the companion okay so these documents
yes they talk about how the narrations
were compiled using these nuts yeah
he's very important because it's like we
don't understand
if he comes to you
if he comes to you if he comes to you
with the news if Allah said if a sinner
comes here with the news
so if if a sinner comes to you with the
news better fight so that's why
we what we do we have something called
praising or criticizing and praising so
before we take any Hadith
likewise
slowly yeah surely I'm slow I'm not Club
yeah yes if
awesome
why why what's in the hadiths is in the
Quran yes
so those things which are not in the
Quran
we have to know other authentic and to
do this we have to see have there been
there is now yeah no it's not like the
condition is
to be trustworthy honest with a strong
memory yes yes and also they have to met
each other yes yes and also there's no
hidden the defect yes yes likewise
doesn't oppose what is known by the
other narrators who are more trustworthy
yes you understand so for example also
there's enough even the text we have we
check the text as well sometimes maybe
this is authentic but the text is not so
not every Hadith not every Hadith I want
to digress yeah yeah
no she either
yes
so some is not
it might not be correct the text yes
so now you make it worse for me no it's
not worse that shows you up
and offensive by different winner ways
if I know who is hot at all therefore I
know who shot no so so that shows you
that we we paid great great attention to
make sure
before that before something yeah
because I want to be consistent here
our new place so we are still looking
for the place of course if you haven't
seen it go back to our channel to see
our current place in the back of the
alleyway in the market the place is not
a good place so we are raising money to
find a new place please donate
generously and the the the details is in
the description box
the Bible that you follow how do you go
oh how you got it
there's no problem I'm gonna answer this
but we have to finish this point
respectfully respectfully outside you're
running away
I'm sorry you're running please
no because Jesus did Jesus make everyone
happy
you've been happy or not it's not a
criteria for my knowledge to be correct
or not you can be happy or not so much
you know that Jesus did not make
everyone happy there are some people not
happy with Jesus answer but yet you
still believe this answer was correct
so okay sir sorry I don't mean the route
anyway so okay so so I'm not ask any
more questions where I was going about
this and that and about the Hadith
should we stop there if it's a new
question by the same question because
you got me a problem which I want to
help
so some hadiths
we have to check the authenticity is
that we've had we're business okay when
we look at his nut you said but some
ideas they may have this nut but some
Hadith is still wrong right right
because they don't go by the criteria
what criteria what criteria you listed
five things to be honest
because you've got to go with the Quran
yeah because there's a case
the other narratives and this was called
hidden defects and who knows this is a
Scholars yes so anybody in the street
I'm just saying now can write about the
Quran say this is a Hadith and this is
what it is and you will accept this as a
Hadith if at least it agrees with the
Quran okay you make Hadith and tell me
it's accepted
so he said anyone can make Hadith and we
accept it that's not true there's no
children away it's not shooting away
because if someone now comes to me and
let's Hadith with the names the scores
Hadith there's a thousand books
these narrators
they don't even exist
okay there exists we'll set arguments
you get narrated and he makes them hang
on this narrator he was not the same
time as the other narrator for it all
right okay maybe there was 10 times this
narrator you said he had it directly but
that's not true because what is known by
many scholars he he read it from the
book bro our knowledge is so deep more
deeper than FBI investigation and I want
to understand I want to learn no he's
not clearly you said if you want to
learn the original question
yeah when I say I leave this question
is one year if you know if you don't
know it doesn't mean you are wrong you
just mean you don't you don't know
everything yeah
so what year is the document now this
document the the Muslim had which says
these are the hadiths and these are
these nuts which is all correct
what date is
companies
100 years after Christ
in the country on these nights
another one which is
so we have many documents and also I
have to remember when it comes to
manuscripts you have to no no before
that can you tell us about who came to
our countries and banned our scriptures
is you know the Crusades or they came to
Andalusia and they burned the Muslim
scriptures yes likewise when they came
to Baghdad the moon goes so it is not
logical for the Christian to ask us
about the earliest manuscripts when
themselves banned our manuscripts
Allah survive it also our relationship
our religion is not based upon
manuscripts our religion is a living
religion that's why there's a saying
they said
do not take a knowledge from someone who
owes it takes it from the book likewise
the Quran from someone who only lends it
from they must have you have to have
this net and everything even it's not
how you know what school said he said I
will even look for it's not God to
Prophet Muhammad how to scratch my head
so please don't confuse me as Eastern
Orthodox Christian to the Christians of
the Crusades
is
the full New Testament did you know it's
after Prophet Muhammad
okay I don't agree there
the claim that this Bible was written
and the actual manuscripts for example
imagine someone said you wrote his books
out of this book in the year 2023 yeah
but the earliest manuscript for my book
was founded 200 years later so you have
differentiate between win the earliest
manuscript for my book was discovered
and when actually was written okay so
we're talking about when the actual
manuscript was discovered when it was
written when actual the earliest
manuscript for the new testament which
is the size of credit card was found
115 years after Jesus so between Jesus
and this small one 150 years let us say
for the second argument the full New
Testament was written 300 years after
Jesus so there's a 300 years Gap who
wrote that manuscripts so
just and I agree with you yeah but
when you put the church father's quotes
together but please allow me to finish
up when you put the church father's
coach together you can compile the Bible
long before
first of all you gotta ask the question
is
it was compiled in one in one say 300
often but that doesn't mean the books
didn't exist before are you Catholic by
the way no I'm Eastern Orthodox okay so
the church fathers of Ethiopian East
European the churches
Orthodox Christians fathers there are
different than the church fathers of the
Catholics of the Roman Catholic because
they said they're different yeah but
before 1054 when we split from them yeah
it was the same no no no nothing is not
same as you okay the church father of
nazaris they're not scared as you the
church
is not the same as you okay the problem
now is this so so the church fathers
these argument is not really the problem
now is we are going on another question
no we're not we're not suggest you stick
to this no I'm sure you want to talk
about it no I'm sure you want to talk
about the Transformers okay let's
understand how the Bible was comfortable
yeah a church father that they have the
full Bible
first of all they don't Orthodox
Christians the Protestants they go with
solar scripture whatever is in the Bible
that is it
he's got to work yes
I agree and that's what I'm saying don't
confuse just because of the Bible
because my point is before the Bible was
compounded he used to know for Dr the
first Jewish Christians and the Greek
that's correct let me let me finish off
memorize the Quran we have memorized the
signs of Jesus what was said it was
grown out as of a community in eastern
reflection stop let me finish you got
the first island to become Christians
answering the question the first island
to be Christian you know well is well
you know now it can be in my country
disciples the church is there all
Eastern alpha dogs it's not the teaching
me exactly the same so the first person
they are the people
what is now historically speaking and I
would highly recommend you to watch the
debate between uh William Dallas and
Bart Airman yes they were speaking about
but Emma is an expert he speaks language
Greek he speaks English and Hebrew I
think as well yeah and he mentioned even
William Dallas who is a Christian uh he
said clearly we can not really be sure
what Jesus said because we don't have a
manuscript for you to say to me the
church fathers how the whole new
testament doesn't make any sense because
the New Testament was colonizing way
after their some scriptures
there's some scriptures
new testament which was not even there
absolutely 100
in the early church
we don't believe
okay
we just finished this Sunday
as yourself
the early Christians the first
Christians the Jews who were the first
Christians who went to Cyprus he went to
Greece what is the problem he's not let
me finish okay
it's a big problem one minute yeah
Barnabas went to Cyprus yes uh the many
saints went to Cyprus one minute they
went to Italy wrong they went to Greece
they went all these people okay they
were awful Ducks Christians the teaching
was always the same just because it was
canonized to protect because there were
many people coming in like the Shia
trying to change things we had to have
the canonization to show and the and the
the nice thing free to protect the
teaching and what was I am lost again
my point is
the Bible
you say to me that we and we we by going
back to church for this you can get the
full New Testament yes that's not true
Justice
Poli had no clue about Mark Luke John
themselves they never witness the New
Testament then it would even ex it was
even in existence in their times
that's why the earliest manage to the
earliest people there were nazares
nazaris they were followers from Jesus
that's why they Matthew they they gospel
is different than your gospel
how are you gonna destroy it man Paul is
the problem you know no you know uh it's
not food it's not a problem but it's
another argument to God no it's not it's
the argument about the Bible
it says
no it doesn't matter because right it
doesn't and in the Old Testament
200 Years BC before Christ literally
nearly one thousand thousand years after
Moses so the Quran that you have there
is one thousand years
the Old Testament
yeah I wanna see the Surah that we have
is agreements is 1000 after Moses yes
but you still accept it even though we
don't have we don't know who else is and
we don't have a chain of narration
between Moses and the earliest
manuscript of the Torah you should
accept it
I don't know
that the solar it can refresh the Old
Testament also it can be referred to the
five books only until about the five
books specifically for the five books
that we had the earliest manuscript we
have which is
one thousand years gap between the
manuscript and Moses yes so yeah okay so
we don't know who wrote it firstly we
don't have a snack for it secondly in
your book do you still accept it and
your Scholars accepts it as the word of
God even though there's no shade of
narration
foreign
because
the first of all 6 50 and after 80 when
the prophet time that was when book
binding start and they can put it
together to manage schools the years of
Moses and the years of Jesus they never
had books they had to be scribes yes he
makes the right manuscripts and
manuscripts or manuscripts and the
scribes the way to play some will find
him wrong some were found in Greece
somewhere
were not familiar with books on the
rocks and we can go back you know so
anyway Douglas the frontier is
regardless if he was there or not you
still accept a book
could be with the word of God even
though there is one thousand years ago
and there's no snap and we don't know
how much
well of course you can answer why I mean
even as respect even a murder who
commits a murder is going to tell you
why he did it
right because you look up with the
prophets and the Prophecies of Jesus
like in Daniel when it's going to come
and in Isaiah when it's going to come
how it's going to be broken how it's
going to be crucified it's going to be
crucial
you guys know we are raising money for a
message a message which we need you need
the community needs and as you know the
situation in the Masjid is a dire one we
got rats who got bin bags we've got all
sorts of things along the pathway just
before you even reach the mission and
the message as you know due to its size
cannot capacitate the amount of people
that we have in this growing Community
as you know remember
Allah
will build him a house in Paradise we
want houses in Paradise but Now's the
Time to work Now's the Time to put the
investment in this life for the
afterlife so what were you doing about
it
let's try and let's really try to put as
much as we can into this campaign to the
best of our abilities rather fellow
people
Everlasting father no one called Jesus
Everlasting father rather that's a high
receipt yeah so how you claim that is a
prophecy about Jesus will we know Jesus
his mother never called Everlasting
father nor his disciples even you you
cannot pull himself
but you know let me answer this
says there are many prophecies what
prophecies you agree about Jesus
uh the prophecy about Jesus maybe I will
agree
there is one which is African either
Isaiah or something I can't remember out
of about 300 no no no there's no 300.
even there is more than four to be
honest along with that Christian
misquotes and I can show you how your
Bible I'm not going to show you cannot
trust your Bible you know what even
forget about the church fathers you
cannot trust the rights of the Bible
themselves how they misquotes uh Hosea 9
1 they claim I'll show you
[Laughter]
he said I will call him my son and I
will take him out of him out of Egypt
out of Egypt yes I want to get it man
yeah
yeah this is my son who this is
my son I'll show you how you can adjust
your life I took him out of Egypt
out of
[Music]
chips
okay so this is
Matthew 2 15. got Matthew 2 15. no no
let's do it let's do it okay so Matthew
2 15 yeah yeah let's go to yeah
I mean anyone you can use anyone you
want oh no no no what is your one we use
the Greek the original Greek
as you say think so you never let me
answer Jesus never spoke Greek yeah the
Septuagint okay
it was in what language it was in a
Greek yeah in the temple when Jesus was
speaking and quoting from the book of
Isaiah
yes
[Laughter]
substitutions well the substitution was
written by 72 Greek speaking Jews what
is the name
[Music]
um
let me you'd expect me to remember 72
names out of them once I made up of
Korea yeah
so Jesus
sorry go to Matthew 2 15. 3 Jesus was
quoted from the substitution and he was
speaking which means we spoke in Greek
now because of Alexandria the Great
there were many greeks-speaking people
in those days just like there's been
English speaking around the world okay
okay and there was another point I want
to say please let me Justin yeah just
remember
I can't remember
so so Jesus for Greek of course it's
foreign
[Music]
one gospel it says he died on the third
he was crucified on the third down we
have the gospel he was crucified on the
sixth hour okay does that mean his
contradiction I never claimed that no
but I'm just giving the example it means
one was speaking to the Greeks one was
speaking to the to the Jews because they
had three hour time difference using
their time their time so I know they
will speak in Greek
[Music]
this one is the clearest one yeah
okay this is about is in Matthew 2 15
yeah
uh so he's speaking about
the Maggie visits the Messiah yeah so 2
15 he says he had escaped Egypt to Egypt
yeah and uh
where he stay and see the death of the
road and so was fulfilled what the Lord
had set through the prophets out of
Egypt I called my son yes all the
Christian schoolers will tell you this
prophecy is in Hosea all right
he's not speaking about Jesus
yeah it's 11-1
[Music]
yes
yeah
[Music]
all right
slowly slowly slowly here we go the word
of the Lord that came to Hosea son of
berry yeah
eleven one you see Isaiah 11 1.
one
okay
when is that all the child should we
speaking about what Israel yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
so watch this when Israel is a child
loved him and out of Egypt I called my
son Matthew
but the more they were cool the more
they were they went away from me so this
passage is rebuking the other Israelites
yes because it's took them out of Egypt
and every time he called them they go
away from him
so with Israel was a child I loved him
and out of Egypt I called my son but the
more they were cool the more they were
they went away from me they sacrificed
to the bows so this Israel here that
God's speaking about when she stood out
to Egypt they start worshiping Idols yes
so why Matthew is misquoting Hosea
in that one first of all I don't know I
I like it if you don't know there's no
second thing there's no second level but
no no we have to agree one thing though
yeah but tell me before yeah yeah
because I don't know yeah it doesn't
mean you are right and I'm wrong I agree
it's just a good point I agree with that
no doubt about that but however you
Christians call us says that and I'll
tell you there was a debate between uh
you're gonna give me the English
Scholars no no no no no you checked
father no no no you the early Church
Father the judge Jerome the Martyr yes
he had a debate with a Jewish called
hirovia the Jewish
he said to him that many prophecies in
the New Testament is not in the Old
Testament did you know what Jerome the
murder the church father said to uh his
name
he said to him because you have you have
corrupted that the Old Testament I don't
know yeah
let's check it is called the bedroom
let's just do this one
all right
[Music]
here I want to go before before you bury
me no no you buy dirty
guide us to the truth
about everybody
all over yourself first all of us no I
don't think of myself first I think of
other people first
I think of other people's first if
you're sick you cannot have someone
before you have someone you need to help
yourself that's why Jesus no no no
because my faith is in God I leave God
to help the people not me why am I doing
God's word I'm not somebody's my action
is if you tell people do something and
you don't do it people think you
hypocrites
foreign
thank you